you gonna do your take on a breakfast
right yeah we're just gonna do some hash
with some breadfruit - we're not in
California right you know I've been
around the world in the last six weeks
and more importantly this stop is Hawaii
now how are you put on the map because
of this young man here Sheldon one of
the best not just in the island but in
the country lineage if you hear make
sure you get down to it but you're gonna
do an amazing Spanish I grew up with
spam udders you grew up with spam
definitely it's you know as part of our
culture that right after World War Two
it's just a rations of getting our spam
yeah this is a different kind of spam
because you got all posh on me yeah so
this is our slab meat this is yeah but
this is our own take on spam that we
make with heritage pork and then make
this beautiful pates art so you give me
the [ __ ] spam he's got two percent meat
in there and you use the best stuff
smart slab sounds like a Vegas spam and
slabs so you know obsessed with
scrambled eggs 35 million have
downloaded that I'm gonna give you
another insights we've done bugs we've
done chilies we've got mushrooms even
wild truffles
but this is gonna be the first ever I
spam scrambled eggs and you're gonna do
your take on our breakfast right yeah
we're just gonna do some hash with some
bread free - we're not in California I
had no idea we read free but it's kind
of the same texture as potatoes yes I'll
chop it up a little bit of garlic cook
it slow with that they're rendering off
of the homemade spam meat so I used true
up with spam eggs chips and beans that
was a staple at home growing up
on a council estate just outside strand
pont-aven and i used to get so excited
but when my mum started frying the spam
they just took it to a new level however
you know I've never turned my nose up it
now but you are now making your own spam
right yeah we grew it we eat it all the
time oh no we just wanted to celebrate
it and make it our own with some special
pork
I remember and not affording a permit to
go fishing
and I guess I started because I was
eating spam have you been on the I had
to so bloody hot
I mean seriously my mouth is still
burning right I'm gonna ply my spam okay
so excuse me two minutes
down to the stove now this isn't your
average stove this is a unique though
and you'll see why
Sheldon's turn the gas up very kindly in
with my spam and garlic secret here
[Music]
Justin come in sleepy coming committee
you know a sense of their self tender
just for two minutes my place my
scrambled eggs what is it with him on
tinder today even out here in Hana I
know does it work out here
any matches any matches Justin no
swiping
now a great idea by the way
making your own spam
or get that nice and crispy now it's
quite so she says I don't need salt in
there get that Kristen in full Angeles
come with eggs at the end good
so Barney waves on the Big Island but
now he has been in my home now for 18
years well I got four beautiful children
seriously yeah three girls and a boy
that's just like me how expensive are
girls oh my lord you know especially
being up being a chef being on the road
and and come home those eyes melt your
heart don't they on a completely
different level so it's amazing how much
color that's Sam yes and this flame in
terms of those embers would love to
watch well very easily especially with
these lava rocks yeah the heat in his
say I'm just gonna get my eggs we've
just looked up the two milk you know
right Sheldon
so how you gonna serve yours I'm
actually gonna put that down in the hash
on the bottom I'm gonna put a nice
little sunny-side egg over the top like
this seaweed Verde that we were hanging
out we'd got some preserved lemon
delicious right thank you thank you
great right look at this that's gone
really nice and crispy you too you too
full now for the exciting part you ready
I'm doing I'm gonna deglaze with this
chili pepper water that has a number one
chilies vinegar a little bit sea water
right don't blink because I think this
is gonna be the fastest scrambled eggs
ever literally butter in
in the butter in with my eggs thank you
sir that's always so powerful we go to
work but gotcha
I remember do my eye man in Kona and the
energy lab where the run was you know
the marathon at the end of the bike
they're literally cracking eggs on the
rocks and cooking the eggs not the most
appetizing thought when you're
absolutely hammered and barely could
walk I give you props man I lost 28
pounds in one day I tell you what it's a
great way of losing weight do an Ironman
ya know that's coming together nicely
gently and the old salt is salt so
powerful about touch of cream to finish
it love the way you've cooking that egg
literally in the residual heat of that
pan then we fold in the spam we are
getting there I love scrambled eggs you
know that yeah
I learnt to make them perfectly in Paris
with visa wah well he showed me how to
do scrambled eggs and then finish it
with uni and this sort of sea urchin
butter went through and then we put it
back into the sea urchin shell and it
was just breathtaking literally yeah and
it's like you never leave it alone you
go on the heat off the heat on the heat
off the heat and the art of a great
scrambled egg as you know is cooling it
down and making sure it doesn't overcook
so you
chickens on three seconds off my spam
folder tin and literally sprinkle that
spam in that is beautiful crispy on the
ends but right nice and runny I love
that it's gonna be beautiful with
seaweed Verde that I've got a special
one for Justin because he has an old
love fly from Hawaii every time he comes
here he goes down to the ocean to wheat
now cool man oh cool
come on nothing when we weeping
that's where Justin
that that looks
described wars please
so we've got our slab house-made spam
alongside red fruit topped off with a
fried egg and that seaweed Nemo very
peaceful and I have the most amazing
spam scrambled eggs topped off with a
touch of the delicious Hawaiian salt but
finished with a touch of nostalgia spam
in a can
may are you taste my I taste yours but
oh yes it's one place in the matter of
it that looks amazing so I'm gonna
literally just break that egg over
[Music]
and that's what I call hash that
delicious family let me know in the
comments what you think of that amazing
scrambled egg dish and if you missed
Uncharted trust me you can watch it on
the link below or on the NatGeo app